empezamos con datos del más reciente
reporte de copérnicos el programa de
observación de la tierra de la Unión
Europea que muestra que llevamos ocho
años consecutivos en que el planeta
Tiene una temperatura de más de un grado
Celsius por encima de los niveles
preindustriales en estos ocho años qué
pasos efectivos se han dado para
revertir el calentamiento global
muy buenos días Muy buenas tardes
principalmente la incorporación de
nuevas tecnologías
al cumplimiento
de las metas en la reducción de
emisiones
asociadas también a los nuevos
comportamientos de la sociedad civil en
general y de las comunidades respecto
del uso de la energía de la gestión de
sus residuos a nivel doméstico y a nivel
más industrial y también en la en la
decisión de Cómo transportarse y cómo ir
movilizando las acciones ciudadanas que
en el cotidiano es lo que nos va
generando un aporte significativo a la
disminución de gases de efecto
invernadero el impacto es de cada uno de
cada comunidad y que va
a las metas de cumplimiento nacional
subnacional y regionales que deben hacer
lo suyo también en la incorporación de
tecnologías la matriz
el recambio de la matriz energética a
nivel de soluciones integrales
regionales y
la la promoción de la electromovilidad
principalmente o de reducir las
emisiones en transporte y la gestión
integral de los residuos que todos
tenemos emitimos en nuestros hogares sí
Isabel precisamente usted habla de
distintas regiones y comunidades que
deben hacer lo suyo pero cuando hablamos
de cambio climático se suele decir que
todos estamos en el mismo barco sin
embargo El sexto informe del ipcc señala
que casi la mitad de la humanidad más de
tres mil millones de personas son
altamente vulnerables particularmente
vulnerables más que el resto a los
impactos de la crisis climática En qué
contextos viven estas personas y cómo
padecen el calentamiento global
efectivamente
hay una mirada en las comunidades
vulnerables porque cuentan con menos
herramientas para poder hacer frente a
las amenazas y la acción del cambio
climático son comunidades principalmente
con rostro de mujer que tienen que
adecuarse a la disminución de agua para
poder satisfacer sus necesidades básicas
lo que puede conllevar a el aumento de
plagas y de infecciones
y tiene que ver todo con el cuidado y el
cuidado en general está con
esta relación a las mujeres